[Music]
the UK could and should negotiated an
exit mechanism to the controversial
Irish backstop that's according to the
former brexit secretary Dominic Rob it
is the issue that could sink trees may
steel in the House of Commons because it
cost her the support of the DEP and many
of her own backbenchers mr. ARP gave us
some new insight into what really
happened
in those negotiations with Brussels when
he was brexit secretary so let's have a
listen I started by asking what should
happen if the Prime Minister fails to
get her deal through Parliament we need
to see what happens in the scale of the
vote and but I think if is expected the
deal is voted down and it's very clear
and I suspect it will be I think it's
important that we change direction this
deal will have been rejected it could
still be remedied if the EU were willing
to look again particularly the backstop
and particularly making clear that we
transition to a free-trade agreement not
this sort of hybrid of a customs union a
single market you've been absolutely
clear that this is not only the best
deal on the table it's the only deal on
the table I'm a new brexit secretary and
you didn't manage to get them to drop
the backstop so it's fantasy politics
isn't it well of course the EU would say
that right now they want this deal to
pass because it is incredibly good terms
the EU is also a lousy deal for the
United Kingdom and I have had four and
half months experience negotiating with
the EU and I think it's very clear they
will not want to see No Deal that is now
a much higher possibility even possibly
probability how do you know that the
conversations that you were having is
spreads that secretary what I knew from
my time as I've written in The Sunday
Telegraph today that there were moments
in the negotiation where we could have
pressed harder on the backstop
particularly around the exit mechanism
now the EU hung tough and I'm afraid we
just weren't firm enough about that it's
always harder to go back in a
negotiation so I'm not saying it will be
easy but I certainly wouldn't give up
and and ultimately if we go back and the
EU continued to rebuff the perfectly
reasonable proposals we're making we do
need to be willing to contemplate and
prepare for leaving on WTO tones you say
that there were moments that you
pushed harder you were branded secretary
said that that's on you isn't it well
partly but we're a team and of course
the officials led the technical groups
the Prime Minister ultimately was in the
lead and I give my advice and it's
either taken or it's not taken it wasn't
taken well I do want to be careful
because but you know I respect the fact
that there's a hierarchy and but the
idea that we couldn't have negotiated a
better deal I'm afraid is not my
experience we should have been firmer
clearer and taken a more robust line
back in July and I think actually
there's a lesson for the negotiations
which they probably should have been
conducted the endgame the negotiations
should have been politically led not led
by the technical teams and I certainly
made that argument at the time so just
to pin you down what did the EU say to
you what did Michel Barney said he made
you think that there was any movement at
all on the backstop well you could see
this backstop issue coming down the line
it was obvious it wasn't a shocker or a
surprise I made clear we need to be time
limited and finite and Michelle Barney
at one point in one of our meetings said
I understand it needs to be short but
I'm afraid after that the technical
track for the negotiations took it in
another direction and I was very clear
with the Prime Minister that we should
have stood firm at that point and that
was back in July now I'm not suggesting
it's easy to go back you lose moments in
negotiation you can't just call them
back what I am suggesting is that there
is probably more flexibility than is
being suggested and actually we need to
take it we should have taken a robust
line then we certainly should be taking
one now and at the same time though are
you not worried that by voting down this
deal you're risking either no brexit or
a much softer brexit i mean look at the
votes in the House of Commons there in
the last week that made pretty clear
that actually the House of Commons wants
to Russell that control of the brexit
and if that happens then it's more
likely to be in Norway style option or
even a second referendum well I'm not
sure that Parliament can wrestle that
control it needs to pass legislation if
it wants to stop us leaving the EU at
the end of March 2019 a resolution isn't
legally binding it has political impact
but it's not legally binding and to be
honest with you this deal is the worst
of all the
there well it's it's nip and tuck
actually Norway probably is a bit worse
you lose even more control over your
laws and you lose control over
immigration but the truth is I'm not
going to choose between various evils I
want a good positive optimistic brexit
and I think we can still turn it around
this is this deal is is worse than
remaining in the EU then in your I
certainly think in terms I mean I've
said before I think if you look at the
amount of control we lose over our laws
because we wouldn't have any say in how
they're made I think in that respect it
is certainly worse than membership but I
wouldn't be making the case for
reversing brexit and going back into the
EU we need to make a successor brexit
and move forward you've said before that
the EU had been bullying and
blackmailing and what surprises me that
is that the way that the EU behaved
should have come as any surprise to you
of course they want to protect their
national interest do you think Exeter's
likely sound for a bit naive going into
all this not so much naive I was very
surprised in particular about the way
and the Northern Ireland was treated and
you would hear swirling around in
Brussels particularly the people around
SEL Meyer and Martin Selma in the
Commission and some others that losing
northern I that would be the price the
UK would pay for brexit this was
reported to me through the diplomatic
channel as one thing to defend your
interest robustly but there's another
thing in the spirit of so-called
European unity to be trying to carve up
a major European nation and it is deeply
reckless if you look at the Europeans
own interest which is the point you made
safe I mean look at Catalonia look at
the separatist tendencies across Europe
look at Belgium I mean this kind of
stuff feels to me like politics a very
narrow politics in the Commission
trumping the European let alone the UK
interest the same time it does feel as
if it's easy isn't it to kind of sit
here and point the finger of blame
elsewhere no blaming the UK officials or
blaming the Prime Minister blaming the
people around not and Selma for example
unis take some more responsibility I've
seen that's why stepped up to the plate
when checkers was came through and said
look let's try and make a success of it
and the spare
four to five months trying to do that
but the end of the day my first
responsibilities to my country and my
conscience and this is a very historic
moment and what I fear and a lot of
people that are weary with brexit right
now what I fear is if we signed this
deal we would immediately then be in a
course for trying to revise it because
it would Stoke up tensions at home and
with the EU it would just be a thorn in
our side so we will not be able to move
on from brexit unless we deliver a
successful brexit which is faithful to
the referendum and this deal doesn't do
that and ambhiraj has given an interview
in which she says that the men at
westminster seemed to flounce out quite
a lot everyone is looking for someone to
blame well the only one actually trying
to sort out is the prime minister who do
you think she could be talking about
that I don't know
Amba does this every now and again she
did it during the referendum when she
personalized an attack on Boris I'm not
sure if that's aimed at me and it
sounded frankly a bit sexist to me
the reality is I stood up and tried to
make it work but I couldn't in good
conscience go to Brussels and sign a
deal with Michel Barnier that I feel
would be so damaging to the British
economy and devastating to our democracy
so I'm not going to engage in any
name-calling or personalized attacks on
anyone and I've been very respect from
the Prime Minister when push comes to
shove this is about far bigger stuff
than personalities it's about the future
our country you say that this deal is
damaging to the economy and others would
argue that it's actually the prospect of
leaving without it that would be
damaging to the economy well their
recent any course of action we take but
if you look at the short term disruption
that would inevitably be there with a
transition without a deal on WTO terms
it's manageable many of the risks can be
avoided or mitigated but what is far
worse in my view is to take a short term
approaching and not take on that
challenge and at the expense and at the
cost of a much bigger burden price for
the UK economy and our democracy so the
point I would make is yes No Deal would
involve some short-term risks but they
are far they're dwarfed if you like by
the longer-term risks to our country to
our economy and to faith in our
democracy if we if we go down that path
you say short term risks but we've had
some pretty alarming predictions haven't
we
baby formula milk for example needing to
be stopped part medicine struggling to
get through those ports that Dover six
months of disruption I mean this is more
than just risk
well I scrutinized all of those papers
and frankly I can say now is about
bencher that the some of those
assumptions are just not credible so for
example one of the things that the
government's no-till planning suggests
is that every lorry coming through will
take ten minutes to check and that there
will only be two cabins at Calais and
that there will be no attempt by the UK
in this worst-case scenario to try and
mitigate the risk well that's not a
reasonable worst-case assumption that's
the sort of camicazi worst-case
assumption of course we can do it
quicker than ten minutes a lorry they do
five minutes a lorry in Switzerland and
of course we will try and divert some of
that flow if the French take a
particularly punitive approach to zero
go to Rotterdam and some of those other
ports and I don't think those
assumptions and those forecasts that
have come out from the government
recently are remotely credible and I
said that to the officials when I was
Secretary of State what was their
response well they didn't have a very
good one on the facts I mean it's not
it's not about civil servants versus
politicians I just asked the question
for example the French authorities say
that they can check a lorry in two
minutes so why are we saying that it
would take ten minutes a lorry to check
why we define what the French
authorities themselves say they would do
and why are we not also taking into
account the things that we can do to
mitigate some of that damage in that
disruption to flow so I'm not saying
that there wouldn't be some risk and
some disruption they would but it's far
more manageable than is being suggested
and I think just as we saw in put eight
Paul Krugman former Nobel economist and
no fan of brexit he said that the Bank
of England forecasts were not serious
and they they felt that they felt like
they were politically motivated I think
there's a lot of this going on and I
don't think the British public is going
to be cowed by project fear mark - and
you've been very critical of some of the
projections being very critical about
the negotiations and do you think that
the Prime Minister has been a bit of a
pushover then I'm not going to
personalize things but I've said right
from the outset the government should
have taken a far more resolute approach
probably back at the beginning of the
you may remember all that wrangling
about the sequencing you need to set out
your stall very early on but when I went
in and became secretary say tin July
even then it was salvageable so I do
think that we have been and we didn't
found that yet
well no I could see how the deal could
be salvaged but look I'm I went in there
a secretary state part of a team and
ultimately the Prime Minister was the
boss so I gave my advice and if it you
know many times it was taken but on
crucial decisions which led to the flaws
in the deal that I've described around
the backstop and around the future
relationship actually we needed to take
a more clear and robust approach if
Teresa may losers on Tuesday which it
looks like she will does she need to
resign I think she could still even in
the event of a big loss on the vote
which we expect I think she could still
turn it around but we need a change of
approach she needs to go back with her
if you like a best final offer to she
staked everything on this deal is it
really credible to say that yes you can
just wash your hands a bit have a
completely new approach and stay as
Prime Minister
I think if Parliament has voted to deal
down in using the ledge stiff mechanism
in the withdrawal Act that's there I
think she can go and say look this deal
doesn't work for the United Kingdom and
we need an alternative approach and I
think ultimately we need to be willing
to walk away in any negotiation whether
it's commercial diplomatic or political
negotiation you need to be able to walk
away if you're going to be taken
seriously by the other side see if the
cynic in me can't help but think that by
very carefully supporting the Prime
Minister like this you're not really
doing your own leadership prospects any
harm I mean if you came out and an
attack the Prime Minister then it would
be difficult for you to well you can be
a cynic if you like but I'm an optimist
and I also believe that you can have
honest disagreements with people I've
never been the kind of person take a
very personalized approach to politics
but what I put aside all of the
political shenanigans going on I've said
at the outset I will be focused on one
thing and one thing only which is this
historic crossroads for our country and
what is the best course with risks on
all sides you know I've always said I
wouldn't rule it out but I'm just not
going to get sucked in to that debate I
think the public and people watching the
show we think would be very
self-indulgent
be engaging all that speculation we've
got such a big issue up for decision on
Tuesday Boris Johnson runs would you
stand aside I'm just not getting tracked
into it you can yeah I'm sure you've got
various variations on the same question
but I'm not going tracted thank you very
much Dominic good to see
[Music]